back at the dawn of aviation in the
1920s wing-walking
was incredibly dangerous stunt
Daredevils would get out of the seat in
their plane and just clamber around the
wings with nothing but their own
strength
I mean maybe there'd be a pole at the
top they could actually once they were
up there but mostly it was just them and
their strength against 100 mile an hour
winds now there are still a very small
number of folks in the world who do wing
walking that way but in the 21st century
wing walking
we go roughly from 80 to 160 miles an
hour various in between that and we'll
pull up to 4G so it's a huge strain on
our bodies and we're doing maneuvers so
we lift our legs that we can do
handstands and we'll also move around
it's like resistance training it's
really hard work in the loop we'll get
up to about 40 at the bottom and then as
soon as we go to the top we start waving
because that's the nice weightless bit
so it's easier to start then then start
when you're going really quickly you
have about a month of intense training
you practice a finger on the ground
first and then you just go up in the air
and do it repetitively you fly every day
Audio says absolute a purring at
Eastbourne airshow we take off from an
airfield near Brighton and we fly along
the coast for 20 minutes and then they
climb up onto the wing so they come up
in flying on the transit flight the
procedure for them to climb onto the
wing is for them to unstrap their main
seat harness but at all times there they
have a carabiner which slides up and
down the wire their cable is about 60
centimeters long so they can never be
more than 60 centimeters away from the
center line of the aircraft once they
get out onto the wing the carabiner is
then behind them still attached and then
they strap themselves into their
five-point harness which is on the
swivel rig on the wing and at that point
of course then they have two methods of
attachment there's totally different
than nineteen twenties
you
and yet we have -
right I think sort of feed
if
I'm in a really fun
nothing that I can do about
it is enough they can get insurance
today they can run it legally I'm
thinking of
the main difference I'm having someone
on the wing is that there is a
significant amount of drag from that
person it's a bit like flying an
aircraft with your gear and flaps down
you'll need more power to fly and you
need to check the trim as well because
the people on the wing provide a forward
central gravity so at the end of the
show we'll chat to everyone and they'll
tell us what they enjoyed usually it's
when we do the rolls and we go upside
down because they can't quite believe
that we're strapped on from the air you
can't see our wire it's all a bit of an
illusion so it looks like we're not
touching they're like oh my gosh so it's
a bit of a daredevil thing they think is
going on as well kids come up to us all
the time especially young girls that are
doing gymnastics and think oh my gosh
that's incredible
so it's really nice to feel like you're
a bit of a role model for people that is
exhausting that is what are the most
physically strenuous things I think I've
ever done
[Applause]